welcome for the first time in Golden  Gloves history the 2018 Golden Globes  ambassador Simone Garcia Johnson that's  Dwayne the rock Johnson's 16 year old  daughter Simone  she'll be helping to hand out the Golden  Globes this January  I am excited I'm nervous I'm a  combination of all of those things but  feeling that I am so excited for this  whole experience it's gonna be amazing  the best piece of advice that my dad  gave me was just to have fun and live in  the moment and I'm keeping that in the  back of my mind with everything I do in  this journey Simone is the ceremonies at  very first Golden Globe ambassador the  position was formerly known as Miss  Golden Globe I am and I am so blessed  and I'm so happy if the Hollywood  Foreign Press chose to make this name  change and I feel even more blessed and  I'm so excited that I am the first one  and I can't wait for this whole  experience that's so amazing  you